The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Welcome back.
If all goes well, we'll
be joined in a few minutes
by a simple pendulum,
a little robot
that we're going to
demonstrate everything.
It turns out we had
a little license
issues in the last
minute, but we're
hoping to bring down
and actually play
with a real pendulum today.
The goal of today
is fairly modest.
We're just going to think about
pendula, a simple pendulum.
When I say a simple
pendulum, I mean
the mass is concentrated
at the endpoint.
Typically, we assume that
the inertia of the rod
is negligible.
In many cases, I'll write the
inertia in there just in case.
OK.
So why should we spend an entire
lecture on a simple pendulum?
Right?
It seems boring.
Well, I think you
could argue that if you
know what the simple
pendulum does,
and you know what
it does when it's
got complicated
interaction forces, then
everything, because
most of our robots
are just a bunch of pendula.
But more important, I
think, is that the pendulum
is simple enough that
we can pretty much
completely understand
it in a single lecture.
And it's going to be an
opportunity for me to introduce
basically all of the topics
I want to introduce in terms
of nonlinear dynamics
and the basic definitions
that we're going to use
throughout the class,
and I can plot
everything about it.
So actually, even in research,
when we're testing out
new algorithms, we almost always
spend a lot of time thinking
about how it works on
the simple pendulum.
OK?
It's so simple,
but it's a staple.
OK.
So what are the dynamics
of the simple pendulum?
I told you how to do the
Lagrangian dynamics quickly
yesterday, and there's a
more worked-out example
in your notes.
If you pop in the
Lagrangian, the energy terms,
into the Lagrangian for this
system, then what you get is I
theta double dot t plus mgl
sine theta equals whatever
my generalized forces are,
which I've been calling Q.
And for today's
purposes, let's assume
that Q, there's two generalized
torques that I care about.
I want to model
a damping torque,
because most pendula
have some damping,
and I want to model a
control input torque.
OK?
So I'm going to
worry about the case
where Q is of the form negative
B theta dot plus some control
input u of t.
The damping doesn't
come out of Lagrange.
You think of that as
an external input.
OK.
So all together, b theta dot
plus mgl sine theta equals u.
OK?
All right.
So this is a one-dimensional,
second-order differential
equation.
What would it mean to solve
this differential equation?
To really solve this
differential equation, what
that would mean is that if
I gave you theta times 0
and theta dotted times 0,
the initial conditions.
Right?
And I gave you some
control input over time,
then I'd like you to be
able to tell me theta of t
and theta dot of t.
Right?
That would be a satisfying
solution to the differential
equation, if we could have that,
and that's the standard way
to think about solving
the differential equation.
It turns out for the pendulum,
if what you care about
is the long-term dynamics
of the pendulum, that's
actually not a very
practical way to think
about the pendulum.
It turns out if you just try to
integrate this enclosed form,
there's no solution in terms
of elementary functions.
In fact, the integral
of these sine terms
comes up enough
that people created
a different type of
function which are
sort of elementary functions.
They're called elliptic
integrals of the first kind,
and long story short,
there's not a lot of insight
to be gained by
actually integrating,
in just a pure calculus
sense, these equations.
It'll give you an
elliptic function
that you could pop into
Matlab and make a plot,
but it's not going to
give you a lot of insight.
And actually in the
notes, for completeness, I
did give you the
elliptic integral form,
but I won't trouble you
with that on the board here.
OK.
So maybe there's another way.
If I care about what
this pendulum's going
to do in the long term, if I
care about where theta is going
to be as time goes to
infinity, then there
are a bunch of other
techniques I can use.
OK?
And the ones that I'm
going to use today
are graphical
solution techniques.
And it's actually
the best reference
for that is this book
by Steve Strogatz called
Nonlinear Dynamics and Chaos.
Has anybody seen that book?
It's a great book, very, very
readable book, just brilliant.
So it's a Nonlinear Dynamics
and Chaos by Steve Strogatz.
He's at Cornell.
OK.
So let's think about
how we could possibly
solve that system graphically,
and let me start by solving
a slightly simpler problem.
Instead of making u
a function of time,
let's make a constant torque.
OK?
And I'm going to look
at a special case, where
the system has very heavy
damping, just to get started.
Let's think about a special
case, a very heavily damped
pendulum with constant torque.
OK?
OK.
So what do I mean by that?
So in this equation, the heavily
damped, what I care about
is that the viscous forces do
the damping are significant
compared to the inertial
forces of the pendulum.
If you're in fluid's, it
feels like a Reynolds number
argument.
This would be equivalent to
having a very low Reynolds
number system.
OK?
But what I care about
for this argument,
I want to say that b over I
is much, much greater than 1.
Right?
And I'm going to say
that u of t is just
some nominal, some constant u0.
OK?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's not a
dimensionless quantity.
Right?
So if you want a
dimensionless Reynolds number,
an analogy would be you'd
need a square root of g
over l or some time
constant on the bottom,
but this is a number with
units that's greater than 1.
Good catch.
OK.
So why is this the
relevant thing?
So now, if I look at
the same equation,
if I do u0 minus mgl
sine theta equals I
theta double dot
plus be theta dot.
If b is dramatically
bigger than I,
then this right-hand side looks
about like just b theta dot.
These terms swap these terms.
Then, I'm going to
make an approximation
of this right-hand side
with just b theta dot.
Reasonable.
OK.
So the reason I'm thinking about
this heavily-damped pendulum
example is because it changes
our second-order system
into our first-order system.
OK?
It'll just be a way to start.
And that's a general thing.
At a very low
Reynolds number, you
can start thinking of things as
being mostly first order also.
OK.
So now, I've got this
simpler equation.
I want to make one more
simplification, actually,
for a minute.
I'm going to just
forget about the fact
that theta wraps around
on top of each other.
OK?
So just let's ignore wrapping.
It's not a big deal, but
let's just keep it clean.
And to be very explicit
about that, I'm
going to replace theta with x.
Just remember that
we've ignored wrapping.
So my equations now are bx dot--
excellent-- is u0
minus mgl sine x.
Thanks, guys.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK.
So we have a pendulum,
but it's got a boot.
So it's amazing that
clocks work so well.
OK.
Simple, first-order equation,
it's a nonlinear equation.
So how do I understand
the long-term behavior
of that system?
OK.
Well, Strogatz says, if you've
got a one-dimensional system,
first-order, then you can think
of that like a flow on a line.
So let me tell you what.
So one d, first-order,
we're going
to do it a flow on a line.
OK?
So what I want to plot here,
I'll plot it really big.
I'm going to plot theta
over here, x over here.
We're in x-coordinates
here, x, and I
want to plot x dot over here.
OK?
So this is just a
simple function,
x dot as a function of x.
What does it look like?
Well, it looks like negative
sine of x possibly shifted
up or down a little bit.
Right?
Let's say, let me draw the
no-torque input case first.
Then, it just looks like x
dot is negative sine of x,
so something like this.
OK?
Where the height of
that is mgl over b.
Right?
OK?
So now, can you tell me
quickly where the fixed
points of the system Are
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So any time x dot equals
0, we have a fixed point
of the system, and that's
really the first dynamic concept
I care about here is when,
in this case, x dot equals 0.
OK?
And in this case, it's
not too hard to solve
for the 0s of that
equation anyways,
but graphically, it's
blatantly obvious
that you get a fixed point here,
a fixed point here, a fixed
point here, and of course,
every 2 pi, it'll repeat.
Right?
Every pi it'll repeat.
Pretty simple.
OK.
But now, let's think about
the stability of those fixed
points and not just
in a local sense,
but let's really think about
the stability of those fixed
points.
Is this fixed point stable?
Yes.
OK.
How can you see graphically
that it's stable?
AUDIENCE: The slope is negative.
PROFESSOR: So locally,
the slope tells me exactly
that if the slope is negative,
then it's got to be stable.
But even in a more global
nonlinear thinking about it
sense, anywhere that this
curve is above the line,
that means I have a
flow going to the right.
Right?
So everywhere in this regime,
I know that the system
is moving that way.
Right?
Everywhere in this
regime, I know
the flow's going to this
way, and so on and so forth.
OK?
So even without
any local analysis,
it's crystal clear that if
I start the system somewhere
over here, some amount of time
later it's going to be there.
Right?
So I'm going to use
a filled in circle
to describe that
stable fixed point,
and this one is going
to be stable also.
And then is this fixed
point stable or unstable?
AUDIENCE: Unstable.
PROFESSOR: Unstable, right?
Nearby points are going
to leave that fixed point
and go somewhere else.
OK.
But stability is such
a central concept
in robotics and in
this class that I
want to be a little
careful about it.
There's multiple forms of
stability that we care about.
Typically, we talk about
even local stability.
The first definition
we care about
is a fixed point can be
locally stable in the sense
of Lyapunov, which is
often shorthand isl.
A fixed point can be locally,
asymptotically stable,
and a fixed point can be
locally, exponentially stable.
OK.
Who knows what it means
to be stable in the sense
of Lyapunov?
Anybody have an
intuitive understanding
of what that means?
AUDIENCE: We start within a
certain distance of that point.
Well, it's kind of founded
the more we go farther away.
PROFESSOR: Perfect.
Yeah.
So typically, I have to define
some sort of distance metric,
let's say just some
Euclidean distance.
What I want to say
is that, if I start
with my initial conditions
are near some point,
then they're not going to
go away from that point.
And specifically, the way
that the sense of Lyapunov
is written, it says if I want
to guarantee that for all time
I am within this distance, say
epsilon distance of the fixed
point, then you need
to be able to pick
some delta, some
small delta, for which
if I start the system
inside the delta--
delta is going to have to
be less than the epsilon--
then it'll always,
for all time, it'll
stay inside the epsilon ball.
I'm going to write it down.
OK.
A fixed point, let's
say that a fixed point x
star is stable in the sense
of Lyapunov if for all epsilon
there exists a delta for
which if x of 0 minus x
star in some norm, let's
say a Euclidean distance
or something like that,
is less than delta,
then for all t, x of t minus
x star is less than epsilon.
Does that make sense?
OK.
So we've got a simple
pendulum plot that tells us
something about stability here.
Is this fixed point stable
in the sense of Lyapunov?
Yeah.
Right?
It's stable in the
sense of Lyapunov.
Let's say you tell
me that for all time
I want this thing to be
within this epsilon distance.
Right?
Then you can pick
anything, any delta
smaller than that epsilon,
and I know that it's
going to stay inside that ball.
Right?
So in fact in this one, you
could choose delta as epsilon,
and it would be fine.
OK?
So these flows on a
line are certainly
sufficient for
checking stability
in the sense of Lyapunov.
People OK with that?
Good.
OK.
What about
asymptotically stable?
What does it mean intuitively
to be asymptotically stable?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Good.
So a system is
asymptotically stable,
if as t goes to
infinity x is actually
going to be at the fixed point.
If you start in a neighborhood,
then as time goes to infinity,
x is actually going
to get to the point.
So if x0 equals x star
plus some epsilon--
I'm saying epsilon and delta
meaning things that are small,
because these are, when I
talk about local stability,
I mean these small things.
If x0 starts a small distance
away from the fixed point,
then x at infinity
equals a fixed point.
OK.
So can we tell from our
plots that this thing
is asymptotically stable?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I think you can.
I think that this
system we know is
going to go to this, as
time goes to infinity.
I think that's quite OK.
Asymptotic stability is
considered a stricter form
of stability than stability
in the sense of Lyapunov.
Right?
OK.
What about
exponential stability?
Exponential stability
means not just
that I'm going to
get there, but I'm
going to get there at some
rate, at some exponential rate.
So if x0 is x star plus
some epsilon, that implies,
exponential stability implies,
that x of t minus x star
is less than some exponential
for C alpha greater than 0.
OK.
Then, I'm going to get there
in exponential fashion,
at least as fast
as an exponential.
So can you tell exponential
stability in this?
The point of these
methods is not
to talk about the rate
of something converging.
So I think the first
answer is not really.
But if you think about it, if
you were to draw some line,
if something was a
constant slope here,
then that system would
converge exponentially fast.
So I think as long as
your curve is bounded by--
is above some line, then
that would satisfy the time
constant criteria.
OK?
But we're going to use
those different definitions
throughout the class,
so I want to make sure
that they're clear.
OK.
So we said fixed points.
We talked about a little
bit about local stability.
Let's talk about another
important concept which
is the basins of attraction.
OK?
So for some fixed point x star,
some stable fixed point x star,
I want to know, if I ask what
the basin of attraction is,
that means it's the set of
initial conditions, which will
get me to this fixed point.
Right?
It's the bounded region
of initial conditions,
then set of initial conditions
for which x of t as t
goes to infinity equals x star.
So what's the basin of
attraction of that fixed point?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Good.
Right?
OK?
So this entire region here,
not including those points,
but this entire region here
is the basin of attraction
of that fixed point, and these
borders here, these lines which
separate the basins
of attraction,
they're called the separatrix.
Right?
Does it look like it's working?
AUDIENCE: It will.
PROFESSOR: OK.
OK.
So let's just think about
this for a second here.
So I've got an
overdamped pendulum.
OK?
This is the fixed point at 0.
My coordinate system is
sets of 0 is the bottom.
Right?
I don't have to use my arm.
I've got a pendulum right
here, and even if it's off--
can I move it?
Yeah.
OK.
So this is state equals 0.
We just said that, if
the system's overdamped,
then we've got a stable
fixed point at the bottom.
I think we can all believe that.
If it was overdamped, it
would just go like this.
Right?
This is an underdamped system,
but the first-order dynamics
will take it to this
stable fixed point.
OK?
The separatrix of that
stable fixed point
are the unstable
fixed points, up here.
Right?
So an overdamped pendulum,
if it's right here,
will come to rest here.
Right?
If it's right here, it'll come
to rest on the other side.
Right?
That's the basin of attraction.
That's the separatrix.
I think it makes total sense.
OK.
What happens now, if we
start adding control torque
to this overdamped pendulum?
It's just this constant
control torque, what happens?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
up or down.
PROFESSOR: Good.
Yeah.
So remember, I'm just working
of this equation here.
That's going to move that
whole line up or down.
All right?
So what's that going to
do to the fixed points?
What happens if I do
u0 equals mgl over 2b?
You see where I'm
going with that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It might be that simple.
It could be that.
I didn't think it out that far.
OK.
So if u0 not equals mgl
over 2b, then this curve
is going to be up.
Right?
So it's going to be some
sine wave like this.
OK.
And the fixed points are
going to move together.
Right?
So I've got fixed points like
this, fixed points like this.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Why do you say that?
AUDIENCE: Well, just because
it gets divided by d.
PROFESSOR: Oh, it does
get-- you're right.
Good call.
Yep.
Thank you.
Just mgl over 2.
Good.
Yep.
OK.
So the fixed point
start moving together.
Do you believe that?
Do you believe that in the
physical interpretation
of the pendulum?
This one's still
going to be stable.
We could see that quickly.
This one's going to be unstable.
Right?
So if I apply a
constant torque, which
I will do as soon as Zack
gives me a green light,
but if I apply constant
torque, positive torque,
it's going to start moving
the fixed point like this.
OK?
The unstable fixed point
is also going to move.
Right?
It's going to be
coming down like this,
and the basins of
attraction changed.
The separatrix moved.
So if this system's
here, it's actually
going to go around
to this and likewise.
OK?
It's nice you can see that so
easily from these little plots.
OK, and what happens
if I put in u is 2mgl?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Exactly.
Right?
I won't do that, because
I might hurt Zack.
But as soon as this,
at the critical point
where this whole curve
is above the line,
then the thing's just going
to move this way forever.
OK.
So just thinking about
these flows on a line,
you could start seeing
what first-order,
single, one-dimensional
systems can do.
So you know they can
go to a fixed point.
We just saw they can go to
infinity, if u0 is 2mgl.
Can they ever oscillate?
I don't see how they could.
Right?
I said, it's either going this
way, or it's going this way.
There's no oscillations
in a first-order system,
and the mechanical
engineers know that,
but this is a graphical
way to see what
that happens, what that means.
So actually, it turns
out the only thing
that a first-order,
one-dimensional system could do
is end up at a fixed
point or blow up.
Right?
There can be a lot
of fixed points.
Right?
It could be a flat line.
It could be that it
could be stable anywhere.
That's fine, but it'll always
either end up at a fixed point,
or it'll blow up.
OK?
All right.
So it's a general tool.
It's certainly good for
things other than pendula.
Let me just give one
other nonlinear system
example that's one dimensional
and first order, so we can
think about a few more terms.
OK.
So this one is called,
just another example,
this one's actually called
a nonlinear autapse.
Anybody have any guess
what the heck that means?
Even a crazy guess?
It's actually a
model of a neuron.
OK?
I did my PhD with
the neuroscientists,
so I often think about
things that are like neurons.
OK?
If you've ever seen
neural networks,
dynamic neural networks, a
pretty common representation
of a neural network is with one
of these sigmoid functions that
are weighted by
some parameter w,
let's say, a weight parameter,
but that's inconsequential.
All you have to
care about here is
that I've got a first-order,
nonlinear system
with a parameter w.
OK?
And again graphically, we
can tell you everything
you need to know about
the system pretty quickly.
OK?
So who knows what
it tanh looks like?
I just said it's a sigmoid.
Right?
So if you know a lot
about a tanh, so a tanh,
it goes from 1 to negative 1.
This is x.
This is tanh of wx.
For w equals 1, it turns out
you have a slope of 1 here,
and you go up, and you
asymptote like this.
OK?
That's w equals 1.
For w a lot greater than
1, you're even steeper,
but you get to the same place.
So let's say that's w equals 3.
And then if you're
less than 1, it's
going to be even more shallower.
This is why bring
sidewalk chalk to class.
OK?
So let's say that's
w equals 0.5.
OK.
So now, what is the
system x dot equals
negative x plus tanh look like?
If I want to actually
draw my flow on the line,
what's that going to look like?
If I want to plot x versus
x dot here, OK, well, I
could plot both of
them independently.
So I know how x dot
equals negative x looks.
I know how tanh looks.
That function is
just going to be
this thing put on the line
x dot equals negative x.
So what that means
is for w equals 1,
I have a system that comes in
like this and goes like that.
For w equals 3, I have a
system that goes like this,
and for w equals 1/2, I have
a system that goes like this.
OK?
Does that make sense?
So the reason I
chose this system
is I want to tell you
quickly about bifurcations
and how to make
bifurcation diagrams.
OK?
So where are the fixed
points of this system?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Good.
So I definitely have
a fixed point here.
Is it stable or unstable?
AUDIENCE: Unstable?
PROFESSOR: It
depends on w though.
Right?
In one case, it's unstable,
and in one case, it's stable.
OK?
And then in some cases,
in the blue case,
I have fixed points here,
and in the red case, I don't.
Right?
So this is a system which, as
I change my run parameter w,
I change the number
of fixed points,
and I change the stability
of those fixed points.
OK?
It's one of the simpler
systems where you see that.
So a change in the
number of fixed points,
as you vary parameter is
called the bifurcation.
OK?
And you can make
bifurcation diagrams,
which for a system like
this, the x-axis is
the parameter you're changing,
and the y-axis is the fixed
point.
OK?
So if w is less than
1, what did we say?
We've got a fixed
point at the origin,
and is it stable or unstable?
AUDIENCE: Stable?
PROFESSOR: Stable.
OK?
So there's a critical point
here, where w equals 1.
We know that now, because that's
where the slope of tanh is 1.
And if it's less
than 1, it turns out
for all w less than 1, I
have a stable fixed point
at the origin.
So I use a solid line
to say a stable fixed
point and a dashed line for
an unstable fixed point.
OK?
And then for w greater
than 1, what do I have?
I've got three fixed points.
Which ones are stable?
Which one's unstable?
I just used my
plurals in a way that
could only imply one solution.
AUDIENCE: The middle
one is not as stable.
PROFESSOR: The middle one
is not stable, is unstable,
and the outside ones are stable.
OK?
So and it turns out, if you vary
w smoothly, then you get this.
OK?
Where this goes to
1, something like 1.
It's not quite 1.
It's around 1.
It's whatever 1 plus
the tanh of 1 is.
OK?
It asymptotes like this, and
this fixed point in the middle
remains, but it
becomes unstable.
OK?
So bifurcations are a critical
concept in nonlinear dynamics.
Give us a crash course.
This is actually called
a pitchforked bifurcation
for obvious reasons.
Right?
And that's actually
a pretty common one.
You'll run into many others.
There's saddle bifurcations,
and there's also,
I think there's just
strangely named ones.
I think there's a
blue sky bifurcation.
Pretty much any name you
look for, you can find
a bifurcation named after it.
OK.
So good.
I think we know a
lot of what there
is to know about first-order,
nonlinear, one-dimensional
systems.
OK?
I think in a lot
of classes, we're
trained to think linear systems,
linear systems, linear systems.
I can do everything in linear.
It turns out, you
can do everything
in a nonlinear
system too, if it's
first-order one-dimensional.
But that's an important axis
that we don't see too much,
I think, and it helps to know
what all these concepts are.
I think Zack says can now do--
can we do the overdamped.
ZACK: Sure.
How overdamped do you want it?
PROFESSOR: We wanted
gravity to be at 0.8.
ZACK: OK.
PROFESSOR: And we wanted
to damping to be, I think--
I'm sorry.
Damping is negative 8, and
gravity was positive 0.85.
ZACK: OK.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So what do we have here?
We've got a big motor,
a little pendulum.
Yeah?
ZACK: Could you move
it into [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: Can I move it?
Yeah?
ZACK: As long as we don't--
PROFESSOR: Don't pull the power.
Right?
Good.
That's fine.
OK.
Big motor, DC motor.
There's a gearbox
here, but we're
going to be commanding
current which is just
like applying that
torque there, modulo
some errors in the
gearbox, and just
an otherwise passive pendulum.
OK?
So Zack has written the
basic system identification,
so we know what the mass
is, what the damping is.
It's not quite the simple
damping I showed you,
but it's not too much worse.
And now, he can do
things like cancel out.
He can change the damping.
He can remove the damping.
He can add more damping.
He can change gravity.
Its just the feedback
linearization game
we said yesterday.
All right.
So we just said we're
going to make it
an overdamped system here.
So there you go.
Now, overdamped is
actually the hardest one
I'm going to show
today from the control
plane of view, because you get
chatter like crazy when you--
[BUZZING] See?
Because there's an
encoder that's discreet,
and we're sampling it.
OK.
So that's an overdamp.
Now, can you give me a little
bit of a constant torque?
ZACK: Sure.
PROFESSOR: Like 0.1.
ZACK: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: I changed
it to the gain.
ZACK: I know.
I'm trying to figure
out where that--
PROFESSOR: It's--
ZACK: There.
PROFESSOR: I think it's
probably that torque.
Yeah.
ZACK: Yeah.
OK.
How much do you want?
PROFESSOR: 0.1.
ZACK: OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK.
So I applied 0.1 of torque.
Actually, we've got a sign
error compared to my things,
but that's OK.
Now, I've got a
fixed point here.
Right?
So the same overdamped
pendulum, it's stable here.
There's a little bit
of stiction in here,
so it's not going exactly.
OK.
The other place we feel
it is right up there.
That's the other fixed point.
Right?
If I put it over here,
then that constant torque
moves me right over
there, just like I said.
OK?
It's all good.
Let's just-- we can play
with it a little bit now.
So give me maybe twice the
gravity or something like that.
ZACK: OK.
PROFESSOR: Right?
What's going to happen
if I double gravity?
AUDIENCE: Nothing.
PROFESSOR: What's that?
PROFESSOR: Nothing.
ZACK: Let me turn this
damping gain back down.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Good idea.
OK?
ZACK: OK, and now we
want twice gravity?
OK.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Changes the natural
frequency, right?
We're going to see
that in a second.
I didn't actually do all
this secondary stuff yet.
Still got high damping
in there though.
ZACK: Yeah.
Oh.
Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
ZACK: Take that out.
PROFESSOR: Cool.
So we're going to
play with that again,
when I do the
second-order version here.
But at least I hope
you believe wherever
it went the constant torque
overdamped tells me everything
I need to know about
the simple pendulum,
so that's kind of cool.
OK.
Let's get rid of this
overdamped constraint which
is the only reason
it was first order,
and let's get to the
second-order case.
OK?
But before we do
the whole dynamics,
we'll make another
quick assumption.
Let's do a different
special case.
I could have left that, I guess.
Let's do an undamped pendulum,
and we'll start with 0 torque.
OK.
So b equals 0, and u0 equals 0.
OK?
All right.
So what do those
equations look like?
Now, I've just got I theta
double dot is negative mgl sine
theta.
Right?
OK.
So how am I going to
graphically investigate
this second-order system?
Well now, there's two things I
care about evolving over time.
Right?
I need to know what
theta does over time,
but I also need to know what
theta dot does over time.
OK?
So I'm going to need a
two-dimensional plot,
and this is the phase plot.
OK?
So let's make a phase plot.
OK.
So a phase plot, what
I'm going to plot
is theta versus theta dot, and
what I'm going to plot is not--
my separatrix doesn't
want to go away.
What I'm going to plot on
this, it's a vector plot.
OK?
I'm going to plot I have
two equations floating.
Right?
This is the second-order system
is equivalent to two equations.
One is theta dot, looks a
little silly to write this,
but you can think of
a second-order system
as coupled first-order
systems of two variables here,
and this is mgl sine theta.
OK?
So what I'm going to
plot here is a vector
which is theta dot
versus theta double dot
as a function of
theta and theta dot.
I see angry looks.
Right?
I can write this as,
if I want to think
of this as a
first-order system, I'm
going to say that x
is theta, theta dot.
Right?
And now, I can write x
dot is some function of x,
a first-order equation
which describes
this second-order system.
OK?
It's a vector equation, and what
I want to plot is, for all x,
I want to plot x dot.
x is 2 by 1, and it happens to
be theta dot, theta double dot.
And it's a function
of a 2 by 1, so I'm
going to make a vector plot on
this two-dimensional system.
OK?
Maybe as I start drawing things,
it'll become crystal clear.
OK.
So given this equation here
for the undamped pendulum,
let's plot some of the vectors.
OK?
So it turns out that
it's simple to think
about it along the line
of theta dot equals 0.
Let's think about that.
I have a vector who's y
component is going to be 0,
and its x component--
sorry.
This component is going to be 0.
I should call it
the x component,
and its y component is going
to be negative mgl sine theta.
OK?
So at 0, I've got nothing.
Here, I've got a little
vector going down.
Its y component is this.
It gets back to another 0.
So if I plot this vector field
along that line, I get this.
Right?
OK?
If I plot it up at some
positive-- or let's
even plot it now
along the other line.
So if theta is 0,
then I get a thing
that's only got an x component.
This term is 0, and it's
actually a linear thing,
so it just looks like this.
You with me on that?
OK?
And if I plot something in
between some positive x,
some positive theta,
positive theta dot,
then I'm going to get a
combination of these two
things.
I'm going to get a
vector like this.
Right?
If you plot that
through, or if you
hand it to Matlab to plot
it through, for instance,
then you can again graphically
quickly interrogate
the nonlinear dynamics
of the system.
OK?
So in this phase
plot, if I start
with some positive
velocity and 0 angle,
then I'm going to
get some angle.
Right?
I'm going to go around until I
get to the theta dot equals 0.
I go around.
That could have been more
circular, but you get the idea.
OK.
It turns out in
here, things really
do look like circles
around the origin,
and they should be cocentric.
Out here, the nonlinearity
shows up a little bit more.
You get these eyeball
looking things.
OK?
All right.
So what does that say?
So if I start my
pendulum-- is it--
ZACK: It's ready.
PROFESSOR: OK.
If I start my pendulum with
0 position and some velocity,
is it 0 damping
[INAUDIBLE] good man.
OK.
Then, what's it going to do?
It's going to start
oscillating forever.
Right?
As close as we can to canceling
out damping by measuring it
and subtracting it.
OK?
So it's just going around.
It's got some positive
theta, negative theta dot,
positive theta dot,
negative theta dot,
and it was pretty close.
I'll give you a better
chance by going like that.
OK?
And I can really test our
model by starting it up here.
That's pretty good.
Right?
So if I start way up here, it's
going to take these orbits.
OK?
And it turns out, if I were to
wrap the pendulum around once--
again, now I'm testing
the encoder counts.
ZACK: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
Well then, I would do
the same thing but over
by that other fixed point.
Right?
So this whole pattern
repeats over here.
Right?
ZACK: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yep.
PROFESSOR: Oh, great.
We should plug that
in which is going
to be mechanically impossible.
OK.
ZACK: There we go.
PROFESSOR: You can sort of
see there's an eyeball there.
Right?
This is the real data
from the encoders.
OK?
So I moved it around there,
and then I jerked it over here.
I got an orbit there,
moved it over here,
and got that nonlinear orbit.
OK?
That's the exact same phase
plot that we just did.
OK.
So now, where are the
fixed points of the system?
On a phase plot, two variables,
where can the fixed points even
be?
Can I have a fixed
point up here?
If I have a velocity, I
don't have a fixed point.
So right away, you
know you're only
going to be looking for fixed
points on the x-axis here.
Right?
And again, on the x-axis,
it just reduced to the sine.
So I've got a fixed point here.
I've got a fixed point at pi.
I've got a fixed point at 2 pi.
Right?
OK.
Are they stable?
Is this one stable?
You should ask, what do I mean?
One more sense.
Good.
Is it asymptotically stable?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
Right?
If I start it here, it's just
going to go around and around
and around forever.
It's not going to
get to the point.
Is it stable in the
sense of Lyapunov?
Yes.
Good.
And this one is
not stable at all.
Right?
OK.
Cool.
All right.
Let's add a little damping in.
What happens if I add my
damping back in but leave
my torque off?
What do I get then?
I want to ask you
one more question.
So this thing is a trajectory.
I didn't tell you
carefully what--
this is a closed orbit.
Right?
Is that closed orbit stable?
AUDIENCE: What do you mean?
PROFESSOR: That's
a fair question.
What do I mean?
So we have to define orbital
stability, and we will.
But just intuitively,
what do you feel about--
do you think that trajectories
that are near that
are going to get to that?
No, right?
This is the same sort of
marginal stability case
that you see here.
So if there was a
sense of Lyapunov sort
of definition for the orbit,
then we might say that.
It's not a limit cycle stability
we're going to talk about,
where it's not going to
converge to that trajectory.
OK?
If I'm on this orbit, and
I give it a little push,
then it'll start moving
in this different orbit.
OK?
OK.
Now, what happens if
I do the damping case?
So my equations are--
I think it's just
unsatisfying to see that.
Let me just write x dot is still
going to be theta dot out here,
but now it's going
to be negative b
theta dot minus mgl sine theta.
Right?
It turns out, if I make that
same plot, at the origin
all is well.
It's the same thing.
Right?
I still get my sine wave
dynamics at the origin.
OK, but what happens up here?
Now, this is still theta
versus theta dot phase plot,
but now when I have 0 theta,
I have the same x component,
theta dot, but now I have
some negative y component.
Yeah?
So I'm going to get a
vector that looks like this,
and these things
go down like that.
OK?
And in general, it looks
something like this,
and what are my trajectories
going to look like?
AUDIENCE: Spirals.
PROFESSOR: Spirals, good.
Right?
You might want to restart it.
I might have moved it too quick.
It's got to grab the encoder 0.
ZACK: OK.
PROFESSOR: OK.
That's no damping still, right?
ZACK: Yep.
PROFESSOR: Let's put
some damping in there.
ZACK: No, wait.
That's with normal damping.
PROFESSOR: Normal damping.
ZACK: Yeah, not
doing anything to it.
PROFESSOR: OK, so this
is normal damping,
just the damping from the motor,
the friction and the gearbox
mostly probably.
OK.
Let's see a phase plot.
ZACK: OK.
Let me get the data off it.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
ZACK: There we go.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So you'll see a few
blips in the plot.
That's when the encoders
are slipping away,
but you can see a pretty
spirally trajectory.
I think if we triple the
damping or something,
it'll look more compelling.
ZACK: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Let's try that.
Yeah?
ZACK: OK.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So while he's
setting that up, what
happens to the fixed
point over here?
It's going to have some
sort of dynamics over here.
OK?
Right?
It's going to have spiral
dynamics down here,
but what happens if I start
with a really large velocity
or a really large negative
velocity, let's say, and 0.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Right?
So this is my
unstable equilibrium.
If I'm coming down,
and I don't make it
to that unstable
equilibrium, then it
will actually tip back
up, and I'll go in
and spiral to this fixed point.
Right?
So let's see how--
ZACK: You going to
give that a try?
Let's do just the normal--
ZACK: OK.
It's ready to go.
PROFESSOR: OK.
OK.
That was the benign case.
We'll try the high energy
case in just a second here.
ZACK: Let me get that
data [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
ZACK: There we go.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Minus the little blips, you can
see that's the spiral going in.
Now, let's see if I can--
ZACK: Let me restart the--
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
Let me leave it.
ZACK: OK.
PROFESSOR: OK?
Yep.
So it looks like it hit the
brakes here and came back down.
You might think it's like a
discontinuity in the trajectory
or something, but
hopefully, it'll
look exactly like what I
pictured up on the board.
Yep, again, minus the
encoders slipping,
and this is me lifting it.
It goes around and
finds, stabilizes
into that fixed point.
OK?
All right.
So finally now, for
those of you that
are quite familiar
with dynamics,
thank you for listening.
Let's think about
controlling this system.
OK?
What does it mean to
control this system?
Let's say, I put in u again.
Forget about constant u.
We're past that now.
Let's say, in
general, I can make
u be a function of the
theta and theta dot.
Right?
And my equations now
are going to have
this plus u which could in
general be a function of theta
and theta dot.
OK?
What is it going to
do to my phase plot?
Doesn't change this
component, right?
Which means things are basically
still going to go around.
Things always go
around this way.
That's how it works.
OK?
But what I can do is I can
move this guy up or down.
Right?
That's all I can do.
Now, in a lot of cases, that's
everything I'd want to do,
so maybe we should.
You want to do the
feedback linearization
of gravity example?
ZACK: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
ZACK: Give me a couple seconds.
PROFESSOR: Sure.
Right?
So it turns out,
that's enough, if you
think about what
this plot looks like,
even if I have a damped thing.
So for instance, if I do
my feedback linearization,
and I make this function.
Let me be a little bit more
careful, I'll call this pi.
I'll say u is pi of
theta, theta dot.
That's the notation we
use most of the time here.
Let's say, I just
made it b theta dot.
That cancels out this
component the thing,
flattens it out, and gets
me back to that plot.
That's actually exactly how we
did the 0 damping case there.
Right?
We just canceled out the
damping to make that plot,
because the real
thing has damping.
OK?
And if we do the
feedback linearization,
we can actually do
plus 2mgl sine theta.
Right?
If I make the controller look
like that then, lo and behold,
the system's now an
upside-down pendulum.
Right?
Same thing I showed
you last time.
This time it's on
a piece of metal,
so that's more impressive.
Right?
OK?
OK.
So here's the name
of the game, and I
want you to think
about this between now
and next week, let's say.
Let's say, I want to
put a fixed point.
You can only put fixed
points along here.
Let's say, I want to
stabilize, turn the system
into a system that's
stable at this fixed point,
unstable here.
I want all trajectories
to end here,
and I want to do it by making
minimal changes to that vector,
by adding minimal torque.
OK?
So you get this geometric phase
plot view of the world now.
What would you do
to those vectors
to try to get all
trajectories to get there
with minimal torque?
Or another nice
version of the problem
is let's say I have
a bounded torque.
Let's say, I don't care
about being minimal,
but let's say I just have
a motor that can only
put out so many newton meters.
Right?
Let's say, that means
there's a limit to how much
I can move those vectors.
OK?
How do I shape those
vectors in order
to guide all system
trajectories where I want to go?
OK?
It's when those
constraints start
coming into play that you can't
just change these vectors to be
whatever you want.
You have to think about
pushing them and pulling them.
Right?
And that's the
under-actuated robotics case,
where you're thinking about
moving your dynamics around
instead of squashing them.
OK?
And for the computer
scientists out there,
I'd actually love to see
what you come up with.
Think about-- write
a program that
could try to in some minimal
way stabilize that fixed point
on the vector field.
I think there's a
lot of ways to do it.
It'd be interesting to
see what you come up with.
OK?
That's the name of the game.
Turns out, there's the right
way to formulate those problems,
I think, is we're going to
talk about optimal control
next week.
The most straightforward answer
I have for the computer science
world is that, if I can describe
some function on my vector
field that I want to minimize,
some cost function, I'll
call it g of x.
Possibly it depends, I want
to penalize actions too,
some cost function,
and let's say,
I care about the long-term
cost over some trajectory.
We're going to call this
thing J, where this is x of t,
u of t.
If you can define a
cost function that
describes the thing I
just said in this form,
then that's going to turn
everything from this fuzzy
dynamics problem into a
strict computational problem,
and we can use all our favorite
optimization tools to solve it.
OK?
We're going to hammer that
out big time next week.
Good.
I think you know
most of what there
is to know about the pendulum.
Anybody have any questions?
You know fixed points.
You know stability in
the sense of Lyapunov,
asymptotic stability,
exponential stability, basins
of attraction, separatrix.
What else?
Closed orbits,
you've got it all.
OK?
That's mostly it.
Let me just say a couple of
the administrative details
that I didn't get to last time.
Your first problem
set is posted tonight.
It's going to be due--
problem sets will be due
basically every other week,
on Tuesdays.
It happens that the
first Tuesday that it's
going to be due is one
of those weird Tuesdays,
but just to keep the
clock on schedule,
we're going to ask for an online
submission on that Tuesday.
They'll be every two weeks.
There's six of them
throughout the term.
We do have a midterm
in the class.
It's just before
spring break, I think,
and so you can
enjoy spring break.
We don't have a final
exam in the class.
We're going to do
final projects instead.
So I'd like you to
start thinking soon
about final projects,
and feel free to ask me.
Homeworks, you're fine
to work on as a group.
I don't care, whatever it
takes to learn the material.
Everybody should turn in
their own problem set.
The midterm, you'll
work by yourself.
The final project, you
can team up with somebody,
as long as the contributions
are clear from each person,
and that's totally fine with me.
Throughout the class,
as you might guess,
we're going to have Matlab
simulations and physical robots
trying to show the
basic phenomenon.
Many of those will
be available for you
for your final projects,
if you so choose.
Maybe I'll ask you to
show me that something's
stable on a simulation,
before we put it
on the robot or something like
that, but it should be fun.
I think it's such a young
field that we can definitely
do publication quality
final projects.
So those of you that
are in robotics,
think about writing
an [INAUDIBLE] paper
for the final project.
I think that's it.
I think we've got a, yeah,
the PDFs from the lecture one
were online sometime yesterday.
Today's will be
online immediately,
and let me know what you think
about this [INAUDIBLE] thing.
I saw one comment last night,
anonymous, but that's good,
and I'll see you next week.